I'm going to start today with something very
pithy and simple that I know is going to get
some of my audience upset with me, and that's
OK, because we can disagree, I think, which
is that Barack Obama, former president, was
right to say that the defund the police slogan
is not a good slogan and that it needs to
be completely renamed.
And I'm actually reminded of the Ronald Reagan
quote, If you are explaining you are losing.
Ronald Reagan was correct and Republicans
seem to get this.
This is one of the biggest failures of the
left.
If you look at at the work of people like
Thomas Frank and and George Lakoff in particular,
about naming and framing and slogans, the
left is absolutely terrible at this.
And when you have to explain, well, when I
said defund, I meant this other thing you're
already losing.
So let's kind of go through it in layers.
Actually, defunding and eliminating the police
as a big picture plan doesn't make any sense.
We've talked about this before.
It's not reasonable, it's not practical.
It's not going to happen in any framework
that we can imagine.
Even places that have done it haven't really
done it.
Sometimes they've just separated up police
departments into different subgroups or units
or whatever the case may be.
Now, some people are saying defund the police,
but they mean something else.
They mean, you know, will reform mostly in
some places, will have fewer police in others
will demilitarize and will change how prosecution
is done.
Well, now you're explaining away a slogan
that doesn't really represent what you mean.
So why are you using the slogan anyway?
And I've been talking about this since day
one of this slogan.
During the George Floyd protests, I put out
like a ten or twelve point plan for how I
would reform the police.
And many in my audience agreed with demilitarization
training as social workers, extending police
training periods, stopping what I call low
effort policing.
It's a very long list which you can go back
to.
And there were some in my audience who furiously
did not agree with me.
And I presume that those same folks aren't
going to like what Barack Obama said.
So what did Barack Obama say?
Let's take a look at that.
If you believe as as I do, that we should
be able to reform the criminal justice system
so that it's not biased and treats everybody
fairly.
I guess you can use a snappy slogan like defund
the police.
But, you know, you've lost a big audience
the minute you say it, which makes it a lot
less likely that you're actually going to
get the changes you want done.
But if you instead say, let's reform the police
department so that everybody's being treated
fairly, you know, divert young people from
getting into crime.
And if there's a homeless guy, maybe we send
a mental health worker there instead of an
armed unit that could end up resulting in
a tragedy.
Suddenly a whole bunch of folks who might
not otherwise listen to you are listening
to you.
So the key is deciding, do you want to actually
get something done or do you want to feel
good among the people you already agree with?
And if you want to get something done in a
democracy, in a country as big and diverse
as ours, then you've got to be able to meet
people where they are and play a game of addition
and not subtraction.
This is simply pragmatism.
And Barack Obama actually lists many of the
exact same reforms that I suggested in my
list some months ago.
Barack Obama is making the exact same case
that I made about actually getting things
done.
That's what I care about.
I want to get things done.
Think about it in those terms.
There are millions of people in the United
States who believe the police should be reformed.
And you even have allies on areas of the right
on that idea.
You have some on the libertarian right who
want to reform the drug policing piece of
police departments.
You have some on the religious right that
want community programs rather than prison
for certain crimes.
You have people like me on the left who want
to end the war on drugs and and police militarization
and solve the problem of it being so difficult
to hold bad actors accountable due to a system
that favors police when they're charged with
crimes and prevents this global national bad
actors database.
You know, all these different things.
You have all these different people who could
conceivably work together on this.
And then you have a tiny portion of people
who actually just want police flatly defunded
and eliminated in some cases.
So if what you mean by defund is the things
I mentioned and the things that Barack Obama
mentioned, then you simply lose potential
allies when the slogan is defund the police
and the police.
So I just don't have time when things are
so critical to be toying around with slogans
that are going nowhere anyway, defund the
police.
Sounds like you're saying we should take funding
away from police who are bad and do away with
police as an institution.
Now, some people do think that if you're somebody
who thinks that we just disagree.
Most people don't think that they think something
closer to my reform plan.
So by using the slogan, you're immediately
trying to explain what you really mean and
that means that you're losing.
Let me give you one further example.
One of the things we need are police officers
from more diverse backgrounds.
And I'm not talking, you know, racially or
religiously or economically, even, although
that would be good.
I'm talking culturally.
You find that in many cities, police are disproportionately
from conservative rural areas outside the
city.
One thing that will help fix police is more
people who would do the job the way.
We want them to do the to do the job people
who are from and even live in those cities
now, typically the cities are more expensive
than the rural areas.
So sometimes police being underpaid and not
being able.
People in cities can't live in the cities
on a police salary.
That's why you get people from the rural conservative
areas coming in because they can come in and
then live in the cheaper areas.
You might have to increase funding in those
cases for salaries to get more cultural diversity
in the police department.
So how does defend the police help achieve
that?
It doesn't.
Now, there's a reasonable counterpoint from
people, including Congresswoman Alexandria
Castillo Cortez, who says you don't start
with the safe ask.
You start with more and you negotiate back.
The problem with that is specifically with
a slogan like defund the police.
Tons of people tune out because it sounds
wacky.
It's not like, hey, listen, we'd like twenty
two bucks an hour, so we'll ask for it and
we'll negotiate down to fifteen because everybody
will participate in the negotiation.
No, it's not.
We would love Medicare for all, but we would
negotiate to a strong public option to start.
And then next year we come back with Medicare
for all.
If you want to get rid of police altogether,
you immediately get a rejection from a lot
of the people that are in the reform and they
see you as a non serious actor and it stops
the conversation.
So, yes, I agree with President Obama.
I think he's absolutely right here.
And we're going to damage our own ability
to fix the problems that we've identified
by using slogans like defund when it's not
what most people mean and it's never going
to happen anyway.
Tell me where I'm wrong.
I'm ready to have a bigger discussion
about it.